as a part of drew's news we'll be
interested
as a part of drew's news we'll be in
it's like steve corral
in um anchorman my favorite he's like
we'll be introducing you to some special
correspondence
and the very first drew's news
correspondent
i want to introduce you to is a young
man who captured my heart last year
when we first got to know each other
take a look
jonah larson oh he is such an amazing
soul
and he's the pre-teen crocheting phenom
taking the needlepoint world
by storm jonah and i met
last year when we did the pilot and we
became fast friends
look remember back when we could hug
jonah's wise beyond his years he
authored his first book
at 11 and he helped create a new library
in the ethiopian village he was born in
thank you
we love you he is an inspiration to me
and i think we have so much to learn
from him
he's so knowledgeable too and he has
great taste in movies and tv
he's so well read the award-winning
life-affirming cross-stitching drew's
news correspondent
jonah larson
[Music]
please welcome my dear friend and now
our friend jonah larson
jonah we're really doing it we're
finally here what a journey are you
excited
oh i'm super excited and it has been an
amazing journey
i know ever since i met you on that
pilot show
that day you were so inviting and i sat
down with you and chatted and chatted
about our hopes and what we wanted to do
and our love of books and libraries
and really helping others and ever since
then
i've been so thankful to be a part of
your adventures and journey
and it's been a wonderful experience and
i've really enjoyed being able to have
you as a friend
oh jonah by the way i
seem like the younger kids sometimes
when we're together just
fyi everybody i mean you're just so wise
and smart and i just you know
i love your mind and your taste you're
also this
you know crochet award-winning crochet
genius and so do you want to just talk
about that really quick
uh to introduce that very important
aspect of your life
oh yes it's a it's a big story of how
crochet has helped me
i'll start off when i was five years old
it was a happy accident
i found a crochet hook in a bag of crabs
and watched a youtube tutorial on a dish
cloth
and i made that douche cloth in about an
hour and i still have it and use it
today
but i fell in love with it it was so
therapeutic
and calming and a really fun way to
relax my very active mind
and i've just always loved it for the
next seven years because i'm 12
now and it really really helped me
in school because up until fifth grade
i was really rascally although my mom
may say more of an extreme word i call
it rascally
one example for example in third grade
i took a big bucket of paint and i
poured it all over the floor in the art
room
and then i backed up and slid throughout
my belly like a penguin
and i have to say as rascally as that
was it was really really fun
and another benefit is that i got to
become really good friends with our
school
custodian and that sort of gives you an
idea of what kind of rasty things i did
well in fifth grade my
mrs quick allowed me to bring my crochet
into school
and i put it in my desk the next day and
when i finished my assignment early
as usual i brought it out and crocheted
away
and my mom never picked pick me up from
school again
so she was really happy about that too
well guess what jonah we're going to
have more stories
and you're going to be our great
correspondent and i can't wait for all
the good things that we're going to do
so stick around everybody reese
witherspoon is next jonah
i just love you so much i can't wait for
all our adventures